good morning
yes yes I'm feeling so so excited about
this conference yesterday was just
amazing you know I couldn't sleep last
night I was my mind was racing with all
kinds of future projects and
collaborations and challenges
opportunities thinking of Brazil India
Haiti and today we're in Africa and and
I'm I'm honored so I want to thank the
organizers Ken Manning
Samantha Tracy for including me in this
amazing amazing conference so and and
I'm very moved because Haiti is Africa
in the Caribbean so I feel so
proud and privileged to be introducing
these four African luminaries and I'm
going to start with um professor
chakanitza mavunga was a full professor
in the program in science technology in
society MIT
his latest book is titled and I love
this title because it speaks to me
personally there to invent the future
knowledge in the service of and through
problem solving I just cannot wait for
this book to appear in 2023 in the MIT
uh press book series on global South
cosmologies and epistemologies Professor
chakanitza is the series editor
his professional interests lie in the
history
theory and practice of science
technology Innovation and
Entrepreneurship in the international
context with the focus on Africa
and I'm very
privileged to say that um join MIT as a
tender track as a professor in you know
eight after completing his PhD in
Michigan instead of Michigan in an album
where I used to teach a long time ago in
1993 before you were born
he's the author of two books both with
MIT press the mobile Workshop the city
fly in African knowledge production in
2018
and then transient workspaces
Technologies of everyday innovation in
Zimbabwe in 2014. takanita is also the
editor of what do science technology and
innovation mean from Africa
they're going to say it's currently
editing a second volume everyday design
maker X from the margins to the center
these volume positions everyday life as
a design maker experience
with strong applications for design
practice
and Canada is also the founder and
convener of the global South cosmologies
and epistemologies initiative which
offers an annual graduate super seminar
co-taught across the world by
distinguished cast of global South
theoreticians and design makers I mean
just just amazing so that's second Itza
and then we're going to hear from ekene
who's a filmmaker and I will have the
pleasure to sit next to ekene yesterday
at dinner and it was just extremely
inspiring and I cannot wait for the
weekend to watch his films on Netflix
um so it can also works in TV production
and in photography its films have gotten
five nominations at the most prestigious
African Festival the Africa magic
viewers Choice 2022 including Best
Director he's done five feature films
three of them have been released Sylvia
in 2018 light in the dark in 2019 one
Lagos night in 2021 all these feature
films have made it to number one on
Netflix in Nigeria and I've been
screened at Nollywood not Nollywood week
in Paris and as at all the international
film festivals in all the continents of
the world including the British Film
Institute and the Durban International
Film Institute akini has also produced
short films like Lasik device 2017 and
counter 2015 and oblivious 2014 Extreme
prolific some of his films are from
Africa's biggest female Awards as I
mentioned before so ekene one for mnet
from 2011 to 2013 then for MTV in 2013
then he started his own company called
Riverside Productions he also runs a
free tuning program
called the imagery program that teaches
young people the art of screenwriting
acting and filmmaking from the best
filmmakers in Africa akinia studied
filmmaking at New York Film Academy at
Universal Studios in Los Angeles and he
also has a degree in insurance from the
University of Lagos and is part of the
Executive MBA program at the Lagos
business school and his action faculty
member at the school of media and
communication Connecticut University so
it's so those African Scholars
really serves people I mean it's amazing
the amount of different things that they
do and now we're going to move to Ruth
Russell congoane
I've been practicing this am I doing
Russell
so Russell is a cultural producer and a
consultant for Creative Industries it's
based in Durban South Africa his work
obsesses or the tensions in Heritage
modernity culture and tradition as they
apply to Black life its practice
includes research cultural production
design Theory writing film and
curatorship is part of a number of
working groups spread all across the
South African region the African
continent and more broadly the world
each unit's work all in South Africa
Europe Argentina and the United Arab
Emirates and Japan
now the best for last
Japan
is a digital cultural Ambassador she's
the founder and creative director of
African digital art a collective and
creative space where digital artists
enthusiasts and professionals can seek
inspiration showcase the Artistry and
connect with emerging artists September
is dedicated to promoting the growth of
the creative technology in Africa
originally from Kenya she has lived
traveled and spoken around the world
promoting a commitment to the culture of
technology in Africa as an artist
African digital artist she's passionate
about creating unique digital
experiences that showcase Africa's
Legacy of Technology
has been listed by Forbes as one of the
20 youngest power women in Africa in the
guardian Africa as one of the top 25
women Achievers so we're extremely
extremely privileged to have this
amazing cast of African innovators and
activists um you know meets today so I
cannot wait to listen to you all so
foreign
sorry I can't put this down in public
because I just received it from a Kenny
as a gift
and also because it's too precious to
put down in case it takes it back so
I'll put it here
okay
now
I think this is the last time you are
seeing the title
um I think it's gone
um
to be replaced by uh soon to be replaced
by a
blank slate
also very deliberate because
when we met for the first time with my
three guests and Friends
we were going to talk about
um
videography between freedom and
oppression
we decided that we don't want to talk
about oppression because it forces us to
have to respond to the Past
we instead want to chat the future
conscious of the role of History
um
in three main ways three or four main
ways
one is that it provokes and evokes hence
Pro evoke
secondly
the work of history is to
act as a tool for
researching ourselves
and by researching it means
that which has been lost
or erased
thirdly
it is a work of remembering ourselves
which is not just storytelling but
storytelling Plus
or if you prefer plus storytelling that
plus is critical because it gestures
towards several other things that are
happening
um in League of Storytelling
and that frame devices we use not just
to use deploy but make
fourth
it's a work of speculating
that's what history enables us to do to
engage in this work of asking what if
what did not happen had happened
and what if what happened had not
happened
now I was trained as a very good
historian
whatever that meant
in
back when I was at the University of
Zimbabwe and then at the University of
Michigan
it is not the work of historians to
speculate to to engage in speculation
but what if
that kind of historical writing is not
for everybody
what if some of us
need to engage in speculation as a
Prelude
to a final move
which is speculative design making
I know design making precisely because
design is not really large
we have to it doesn't come to us well
explained and well understood a prayer
because we were not available
for historical reasons
when this language was formulated
now that we are there it affords us an
opportunity to have to
offer our somewhat belated input
in other words
making what did not happen happen
and
making what happened not happen in
future
now
this
presentation will be divided into four
parts
after this I'll be quiet and just let
the images provoke and evoke
the second part of it and third and
fourth will focus on how we can use
history
as something that is not in the distant
past
but lives with us every day
which some of us cannot Escape
sometimes it imprisons we prefer we much
rather prefer
that it acts as a tool for our
self-rehumanization
and self-re intellectual
and the assembling of our own resources
to live respectable lives
hence
what we want to talk about first is
to look at images of Africa
and engage in an assembling of archives
and vocabularies
for storytelling our creative everyday
and with that I will now shut my mouth
and let the visual
come to you
thank you I will now invite uh again to
take us to the next phase of this uh
presentation
upon calabashi
[Applause]
good morning everyone it's such a great
pleasure and honor to be here today
um so I'll be very brief with this
before I go into Calabash well most
everything I'm going to talk about today
have been inspired from talks with
Professor
avunga here and um I'm very excited to
talk about these things
um so we talk about being Witness
you know and we talk about videography
um but I have a question so
how have we been bearing witness before
we had this little devices that have
cameras enough
you know so are we trying to say that we
were not being witnessed
are we saying we were not fighting for
justice
so I know I'm a filmmaker and I cannot
be a filmmaker without the camera so I
understand the power of camera in fact I
have a job because of the camera
you know but
what I'm trying to say in essence is
that the camera in itself
is not so what is doing the work because
something has to happen for the camera
to be effective
so to a large extent it's as though
we've put so much importance on that
tool and forgetting that the camera in
itself
it's useless if there's nothing in front
of it
so there's so much work going on in that
aspect that we are not looking at and
it's something I thought
to talk about
but that's just on the side so we're
going to talk about calabashing
Calabash
to Africans
Calabash is very very important uh
we used for a lot of things
if you drink Palm wine for instance
we don't serve it on cups like this for
some reason it doesn't taste sweet when
you use cups like this
when you drink it with the Calabash it
comes with a different taste trust me
you know and and um
it sells as a music instrument it serves
as a
um as a jar you know to to
um to keep liquids and preserve them and
a whole lot of other things
so let me explain I mean just for those
that don't know what a calabash is
so
um
it it comes from a plant that produces
something like this this is what it
looks like on the tree
all right and by the time it process
comes something like this
so you open the top and you can also use
as a music instrument as well
you know
and
okay
um this is kind of slightly distorted
but before this sorry oh okay I think
there's something missing okay but it's
fine so we also have some that come in
around shape and it's at the end of it
it gets something like so you see
something like this so we often use this
to carry pamo in and then it's a pine
usually served in something like this
but before I go further yes so you can
also design it to something like this
okay so why am I talking about the
Calabash
so we're talking about videography
you know it's interesting that in Africa
so the camera was invented
um in the late 18th century yeah about
in Africa we have been
in a way
using the camera for centuries well not
like the kind of cameras you have today
so those days
um see the Calabash like this
so we have the
um
well you call them Juju priest we call
them like the Euros called them babalao
or the fat priests
um from where I come from I'm able so we
call them Divya
so they carry the Calabash
all right and they put liquid in it like
water but not exactly water
so those days if we needed to see what
happened that certain
time so I'll give you an instance so
let's say someone steals something and
they don't know who stole it and they
needed to find out who stole it
so they'll go meet the debia and he'll
bring out his Calabash
and they put the liquid
and he makes some incantations
and before you know it
explain you the video live
in HD
so I'm not too sure if it would if we
could do like 3D you know but at least I
will show up HD
you know and it's interesting because
that was how they view things then you
know and it could rewind and it could
fast forward
you know and these were things that
you're doing
centuries ago you know so um you know um
my Prophet was saying
speculative so I'm asking myself I mean
these guys I mean a lot of you are so
thrilled by virtual reality now I mean
these guys were playing with virtual
rights then
so question for me is
why didn't we in Africa look for a way
to develop this technology so that we
could export it to
America and Europe
I wish I had the answer to that question
well
but just so you know that I mean we've
been playing with these things that you
guys are fascinated about now we've been
playing with these things in Africa for
centuries
and
lastly
um
you know there's something Barack Obama
said that um
Africa does not need strong men in its
strong institutions
unfortunately
um yes I it seems like we have more
strong men and stronger institutions
because
the good thing about the video and what
it does is that it gives us an
opportunity to
um gives us an opportunity to
document some of these incidences that
happen and looking at like judge Floyd's
case and the likes but what happens
where
the institutions don't do their work
so even though you have all the
witnesses and you have everything
still useless
so it's something that I crave for um
for the continent and I know it's not
just the continent because even in
places like here I mean
I know there are certain places you
could bring out your camera it could get
shot and nothing will happen
you know so
um it can't work by itself it also needs
things like that to be able to be
effective
thank you for your time
what can I didn't show you was this I
think this is what he was looking for
yes that's how you found out who had
stolen something
you'll make him look into the water or
make a look into the water
and then you could see things that
happened yesterday or that will happen
or that happening now
um the Calabash is also
a very strong instrument for the
electronic and the sound
that we see in video
and so to that extent it is also part
and parcel of a question we are asking
what would it take to create the Next
Generation
audio visual capturing devices
out of say the Calabash
my next guest will begin to speculate on
some of these through some of the work
he's doing uh in film
thanks Prof good morning to you all
thanks for for being with us on a Friday
morning
um so I'll get I'll get right into it
um so I'm kind of sharing these images
as a way for us to
start a conversation as a way to kind of
play with some ideas and to be in
conversation with my colleagues in front
here
um but but also with you all I think
this part part of part of the work
um or at least part of the ideas that
I'm that I'm kind of throwing out here
is to one think of how we situate the
camera
um on the continents that we call and
know as Africa and see what kind of
discourse what kind of theory starts to
emerge when we don't rely on the
vocabulary and the methods and uses of
this tool in in the so-called wrist
um or not so I I should start by saying
I'm one of three collaborators that are
currently developing a project that is
kind of convened and and brought us here
Prof here has kind of been a very strong
inspiration in the making of that
Wilkinson so my collaborators as you see
on screen is Amy Wilson as well as
Franco nozza who are based down in Cape
Town
um so let me
start here so the camera arrives in
Africa with anthropologists
the device is what introduces the native
to the world
a few centuries later of course
introduces the nates the native in a
very particular and peculiar way some
centuries later the natives
have charge and control over the camera
so it starts to refashion and represent
themselves in a very particular way yeah
the question does remain
how do we conjure how do we make up how
do we build the stuff that we would have
wanted to document yeah so what sits in
place of the things that happened and
because there's not the evidence there's
not that documents they are dismissed as
mere myth
and these myths
form the backbone and the foundation of
our cosmology yeah and so part of the
work that we are trying to do with
filmmaking is start to present and start
to speculate it starts to build the
world that we've heard of through myth
and centuries later we see it through
science fiction speculative fiction and
so on and so forth and so
uh much of of the images that you will
encounter are trying to bring some kind
of visual quality some visuality to emit
some visuality it's a productive
possibility that we are trying to build
um and and work from
so
language language
begins to to serve as a repository as a
place of reference for us to excavate
um and pull up some ideas and
imaginations around our past
um of course these myths are articulated
in this and I'll just use one example as
a way to open up this conversation or
expand the conversation so
Ebola
is to is to capture
yes to hold something
when you talk about it in a kind of
Mystic or transcendental Dimension it is
to capture one's soul
yeah it's a way of kind of keeping
diluting of not diffusing time right
and when the camera and comes to the
consonants
and the camera becomes um
the camera person is someone who's able
to capture your soul to capture so to
take a photograph is
a camera person so this idea that the
camera or the camera person is
so the capturer Who can capture not just
a photograph of what becomes a
photograph they are playing at another
dimension a dimension that we cannot
quite understand so quite literally if I
have a picture of you I can do some
things right
but that's not the point yeah the point
is what else is operational here what is
this other thing that makes this
imaginate that kind of mobilizes and
brings fuel to this imagination and
that's the kind of work that I think it
becomes begins to open up the
possibilities and allows us to build a
theory around these tools around a set
of Technologies and devices that have
played such a critical role in
oppressing as well for us now in in
liberating ourselves through through
storytelling
the speculative is a method that I that
I deploy quite strongly in my practice
why because it doesn't it doesn't depend
on on evidence it does not depend excuse
me it does not it does not depend on the
truth yeah it's a gesture
adds or towards something and so these
judges become really really interesting
ways to say if we can all agree that we
did this
all right who's to say we didn't do this
if
in southern Africa is the sites where
they found the oldest gold smelted
um rhinoceros right and this is facts
yeah
who's to say we didn't do these other
things that we want to speculate upon
and speculate about yeah and so these
images allow us to start communicating
with a younger generation yeah kind of
putting together some kind of um of of
official
um documentation
so these images
um are part of a film that we're
currently working on that's called Tata
The Institute for technological
Consciousness and it relies severely or
heavily on images that we cannot find
out there and so what we are doing
through this work is starting to produce
those images and make those images yeah
and they become really really important
because they're not available
yeah so in a way our making our future
making our vulture of future building
um is is in production in in that way if
if you will
and part of it is also trying to like
bring images that even we as Africans
are not familiar too or familiar with
you know
this is made um through the the Dali
program that I think one of the speakers
last night's yesterday
um had shown some images from which
um and towards the end
of my
of my sharing we'll come back and kind
of open up a conversation around these
images so
mind notes lastly this is uh this is the
tete fly and so part of part of the work
um in this film is is working is taking
inspiration from Prof mavunga's work and
starting to to take what was dismissed
as myth and build it into a kind of a a
a a filmic world but also to take it out
of a filmic world world and kind of
start to make objects and artifacts
really as a way to kind of put
technology in the hands of young people
you know amongst amongst other things
and other people so this is a Jitter fly
maybe profkin can speak to this if if he
wishes but it's a sculpture that
Francois who's my collaborator had made
it features in the film and as well it
features in in the book of prophet
mavunga so you almost start to see how
we're starting to build a universe you
know from from myth really yeah but this
myth is something we want to work with
yeah that's Smith is our speculative and
the world is only created and
manufactured through speculating through
playing an innovate and that's where
Innovation becomes possible and then
lastly
um
as part of thinking of the relationship
between the consonants and the camera
more recently or at least in in in in
the more recently there's been a
phenomenon where the camera has been
kind of quite pervasive and and it
enters in all spaces and all circles but
there's also a time when I was much
younger where the camera could not enter
certain rooms it was not invited at
certain events in certain moments yeah
and again
what what is it playing there why why is
it important that the camera has a set
of boundaries
in places and spaces and moments where
it is not invited you know and so what
theory can emerge around that yeah
um again that's a simple that's a simple
question and one could respond in a very
simple question but there's something
else that we're trying to kind of tease
out and and build there so that's the
end of my presentation for now and then
I'll hand over back to you Prof
foreign
it is quite surreal for me to be here
because
um I'm actually quite a nerdy Tech
person and have never belonged in any
space
um so I constantly have to create spaces
so I'm sort of an anomaly like um a very
technological person minded person like
I gravitated towards that as a young
child but then I'm also like sort of
artistic and philosophical about things
I'm too much aware of things so I think
I've always sort of bounced around
between very many different interests
and I realized that I'm very much a
product of my time
so my name is Chip chumba I'm originally
from Kenya and I'm an African digital
artist
and when I was sort of trying to
assemble my education my parents thought
it was wise to put me to an uh into an
American missionary School in the middle
of Kenya that was part of the colonial
project so pretty much my high school
um
time that I was in high school I was
always constantly annoying my teachers
because they would say we're going to
study world history we're starting in
Germany World War one I'm like where are
we we're in Kenya what are we doing why
are we studying this this is pretty I
was basically set up to constantly ask
the question why and in in a strange way
um technology like immersing myself in
technology put myself in spaces in which
I could create things that really didn't
possibly exist before or like have
conversations that moved forward so one
of the things that I did was start
something called African digital art in
2009 as a way to Archive creative
projects all from all parts of the
continent
and the first question that I would
receive from people online would be are
you sure this is African I thought
there's no electricity in Africa
um uh what what is that
um so I I was kind of surprised that
those questions came from both like
people outside of Africa but mostly
Africans themselves and I realized that
we really had not had many conversations
around creative technology so I sort of
made it a point to myself to be sort of
out there and have this conversations of
like what would it look like if African
artists and philosophers and thinkers
and magicians and theorists had this
Internet space to like theorize and like
create new possibilities and sort of the
response to that was like but we need to
solve Africa's problems like first
before we start dreaming like there's
too many we can't even sleep as Africans
we have to fix the continent
so I think in response to that a lot of
the work that I did went into
speculative thinking and dreaming and
then I was called an afrofuturist which
is really confusing because I feel
futurism has a completely separate
history in America than it did from
where I come from where I was actually
much more into like African thinking
about African futures
so a lot of the activities that I did
was and to participate in projects where
it would sort of propel a group of
people into thinking about the future
and somehow
um I went sort of all different
directions
um curating projects that
um really invited different artists to
think and dream about
themselves in in Africa
and and inevitably I ended up back right
back here to these images
that the professor evoked here
um
can I how do I
um as the more I try to propel myself
into the future I ended up going back
into images like this and looking at
them in a completely unique and
different ways where I I was allowed to
now
sort of continue the conversation about
the Technologies in which my ancestors
lived and I was sort of privileged by
the fact that I had by design of my
parents and grandparents always a
connection back to where I lived so I
could literally transport myself back
and live completely the similar way that
my great-grandmother I lived in her
house like my great-grandmother's
homeland and basically adopt a daily
life like that by becoming a farmer and
then I found that this was such a unique
space for us to understand the legacy
of technologies that have been developed
on the continent that are much needed
now in the time that we live in as we
find it increasingly harder to become
human because of the amount of
technologies that we continue to adopt
we constantly have this push and pull
between like trying to make things
different but then always pulling us
back to our tendencies
um so I think I'll stop from there
um and invite perhaps a new set of eyes
and new set of ears to the conversation
that we're having because much of what
we're trying to do is to move past like
our a tendency of like how we talk about
technology and the continent and
um really try to play much more about
like possibilities of the future
yeah
foreign
yes and now questions comments
yes
um hi my name is Karen ritzenhoff I
teach at a State University but I was
very fortunate that a colleague of mine
who is a sociologist allowed me to
co-edit a book on afrofuturism in Black
Panther with her and we got a lot of
contributors from a lot of different
disciplines from the United States and
international authors to write about the
afrofuturism in wakanda and this
Blockbuster success of Ryan coogler's
superhero film and so since you are
filmmakers on the panel I wanted to ask
if you could explain how afrofuturism is
different as you just mentioned
um for you when it's conceived in this
kind of Blockbuster format and what you
think the film did or didn't do for a
global audience did it in your
perception
offer opportunities for
discussions or how do you see the
influence of this franchise that is soon
going to be followed by wakanda forever
but also triggered a film like the woman
King with Regina King
yeah
you did
uh
my first response to the film I think is
that I think that some of us have
completely different imaginations than
what we're offered by Hollywood
um and yes it is great that that kind of
imagination is accessible but it's
certainly not new and the term
afrofuturism and African futures
a completely different thing
um
I would invite us to really think about
the parties
we would have if we had an unreliable
accounting of the past
and how that would affect our dreaming
of the future if you knew that
everything that you sort of understood
about yourself and who you were the way
in which the world worked and operated
was a bunch of stories that could be
changed at any time like how you
yourself living in this digital this
mediated Digital Life that we find
ourselves currently how would you
approach the way you're living every day
um I think that's like much better
offering than what sort of Hollywood is
doing which
um
yeah
I mean yeah I think September has
responded to that really beautifully
I've got nothing substantial to add
I have a question
so I was thinking about the reimagining
and right and and the stories that are
told and not told and wondering what
your thoughts on and reimagining
education
um using videography images and you know
what you started with in terms of grass
and and the Calabash you know those
things in in American Education are not
even talked about
oh thanks Tracy so
I the book daring to invent the future
the subtitle is called
knowledge in the service of and through
problem solving
the reason being my major claim is that
at least focused on Africa
I'm saying that
we are producing useless knowledge
and if it was useful
what is there to show for it
uh it's too theoretical
it has not left the kinds of
purposes for which the colonizer
designed it for
those that dispense it are a part and
parcel of the problem
of an and decolonized mind
what is essential therefore is to engage
in a new kind of knowledge
of mind re-engineering
after amnesia
as Ganesh Dev would say
what is what happened is that
our knowledge systems were stripped of
any essence
were caricatured
and we were pointed towards a knowledge
system that is Western and white
as the only
Bridge
into modernity
we may reject that claim
because it then foreclosed the
possibility of us
seeing anything worthwhile
to go back into our past civil
the other thing that happened is that
the methods
of researching the past we're all about
research
not researching the past in order to re
member
what was dismembered
part of what was dismembered and
foreclosed was
if for example
something was designated as witchcraft
what was emphasized was the witch
what was not talked about was The Craft
some of us may want to now go back to
that question and say what was the craft
and if we did that
we will not just end with speculation
the challenge is to say what after
speculation
because we live our heart on the verge
having discovered this 35 object
somebody somewhere in Silicon Valley
takes it and develops into the Next
Generation technology
based on our imaginations and yet we
would be told that this is just a work
of fiction useless fiction
so it's a knowledge for us it's no
longer a knowledge
for the sake of writing and Publishing
books
books are wonderful
but people do not eat the ideas in our
heads
we some of us have a responsibility to
our communities which cannot be
fulfilled ever by publishing
that would be my response to you
hi my name is Brianna I'm a comparative
media studies and writing lecturer here
at MIT and I have a question in response
to something that Russell said but I'm
sure any of you could answer and so when
we were talking about reimagining and
re-researching and redesigning realities
it was mentioned that we didn't want to
use the same methods of the of the West
and a good example was not requiring
evidence to come to consensus and truth
and I'm wondering if if you also are
thinking about
measurements outside of Western
measurements that would define the
success of those troops so you mentioned
just now publishing or exporting was
mentioned earlier if those aren't the
metrics for Success what might be
I I'll answer this very quickly then
pass it on to Russell I think for me the
question
my legacy will be
how much lives have I touched
because for as long as I go back to my
Village and I find people still work
children still walk five miles to school
in five miles back the same ones that I
I walked and I see kids in South
Framingham continuing to go hungry and
can't find after school programs
that keep them at school doing something
worthwhile
um
and they go on the streets and they do
things that you know create this cycle
over and over again
I don't think in my view I should brag
about being a fully tenured full
professor
that's a very horrific
um
my my measurements perhaps of success is
to have constructed some kind of
intergenerational discourse would say
between
my son and my grandmother
um and and the work that I'm doing is
translating ideas and Imagination that
were contained within my grandmother so
maybe if I give a very practical example
um
through this work we we host workshops
and we kind of play with this idea of
objects of power so if so if like
African masks for example for example
are objects that are potent
um so we kind of invite young people who
present images to young people and we
fill the room with the waste yeah and
it's okay let's let's play like look at
this image look at this image and they
start like asking questions what's this
and how does this stuff come together
and it starts to kind of you know it
helps them make it helps them construct
but it also helps them ask questions
about the world
um and a really important one is that
they are using as a reference
our grandmothers and our ancestors
folklore and and and so on and so if one
can start to bridge that Gap I think we
would be kind of starting to move the
needle in in some in some way
we are almost running out of time
I
yes I have a question actually for a Ken
um about calabashing
um and I wondered if uh it's a very
basic question are the images stored in
any way are they do they remain are they
fixed um because that would seem to be a
huge difference between calabashing and
the video camera and it would really
challenge a lot of the things that we
were talking about yesterday with the
importance of storage And archiving and
this kind of obsession with storing
everything and I I wondered if you could
explain that or answer that very basic
question and then open up uh and and
give your thoughts on archiving and
Storage
okay thank you so I mean it's not the
day that someone came with a tool called
the camera that they started working on
it
I mean a lot of these things come from
years back and you get to a point where
you're presenting something that's
finished and that's why we're working in
the Realms of the speculative to say
okay what if this thing that had been
toyed with for centuries had been
further developed so
I'm not saying that they had gotten to a
point where they were moving around hard
drives to be able to play it somewhere
you know but I I want to believe that
what at any point in time that they
wanted to replace the code replayed
what I could not fully understand was
the whole process and because it was not
something that was
you know for me it's a it's it's it was
just trying to imagine because these
things do exist it was trying to imagine
to say okay what if
because living the realm of the
speculative
if we had decided to go away from this
point and say how could we develop it I
won't believe that if that thought had
been in the minds of this one for
hundreds of years then there was a
possibility that could have been
developed
think I I wanted to respond so in a
matter of storage I think that most
technologies that come
from Africa digital technologies that
have lasted over centuries usually
is to think about it you have to rethink
your way of how technology is that most
Technologies we use today which is very
objective like it's an object your phone
has these functions but most
Technologies had multi-function so the
Calabash for example is an instrument
it's not only decorative it's not only
something you eat it's not only
something it has all of these repurposes
sort of also like print and textile and
patterns that are preserved and also the
stories that are told when making
certain Technologies so for example like
in beading which is in very
digital to ancient African digital
technology it's not only the making of
the patterns the digital patterns on
that are coated on the beads it's the
conversations and stories that are
shared along with them and then also the
purposes and functions of the color
coding of the bead so you have like a
skirt that's a certain color printed for
a certain function over time that is
past generationally so that's like a
completely different way of
understanding storage and also
Collective memory that has been a
contribution that Africa has made and I
think a lot of these like Concepts
African Concepts have really permeated
because of digital and internet culture
and now we are almost like even in our
Communications with people sort of
telepathic you can also kind of
anticipate when your hot boyfriend's
gonna text like and like before that
would be seen as kind of like crazy but
we have this really very nuanced and
sensitive
very intimate relationship with devices
and then all of these components from
these devices come from Africa so
there's like these really Hardware
software cultural like relational
networks of systems that contribute to
the culture of Technologies and our
ideas and imagining of daily life the
past and the future so that's why I
think
thinking about these ideas from the
continent is always so interesting
because there's not so much of
romanticization and a fetishization of
the past and objects that seems to like
occur in a lot of other spaces yeah
yeah uh it's just gone past 10 30 and I
would like to
thank everybody and to thank my guests
for
such a wonderful conversation
[Applause]